here are some things men may not know
about their clothes the Boat Show was
invented by Paul Sperry the sole of the
shoe was modeled after his dog's paw the
dog has no memory of this men who wear
bowties are seen as older smarter brainy
ER and Republican er this button was
inspired by polo players who'd put
buttons on their collars to keep them
from flying up while playing and while
we're on the subject of polo polo shirts
were created for tennis not polo but
back to buttons on collars shirts with
button-down collars are called
button-down shirts but shirts that
button in the front and don't have
button-down collars are called
button-front shirts not button downs the
triangle on the front of some
sweatshirts was originally put there as
extra fabric to absorb sweat the YKK
that is on all your zippers stands for
Yoshida kogyo kabushiki kaisha
and women's shirts button on the
opposite side as men's because women
used to be dressed by servants and this
way the button would be in the servants
right-hand as it is for men dressing
themselves one in eight men surveyed
confessed to wearing their underwear two
to three times between washes and three
of three people we just surveyed said
you after hearing that
Wow